MONAHAN CAN'T GET A CLEAN SHOT
AWAY.
TRICKLED OFF HIS STICK WIDE OF
PENALTY KILL 27thN A TEAR OFFE
FOR WINNIPEG.
HEADS OFF NOW.
SCHEIFELE ELECTS TO PLAY
sportsselect.comCKLUND FLIPS TH.
PIONK
THAT WOULD BE A CONCERN.
HERE'S TANEV WITH A PLAY IN DEE.
SIX AND A HALF MINUTES TO GO FR.
CLEARED BACK TO THE CALGARY
ZOT NOW.
LINDHOLM ABLE TO CHOP THE PUCK
DEEP.
>> Kelly: 12
CONNOR TAKES OFF.
KYLE CONNOR.
29 GOALS ON THE YEBE A SUPER HAG
TEAM.
TIPPED.WHAT HIS DAD
GOT IT BACK.
FANNED ON THE
COACH.
>> Rick: REPLACED PAUL MAURICE .
MANGIAPANE KNOCKED DOWN FROM HIS
KNEES FINDS KYLINGTON.
HE WILL TAKE OFF WITH
COLEMAN RIGHT ON THE TAPE.
AND MORRISSEY RECOGNIZED THAT
WAS A ON.
AND THAT'S TOUCHED GOODS LOOKS E
FLAMES ON THAT POWER PLAY.
GOOD PLAY BY STANLEY TO CLEAR
>> Rick: FIVE POWER PLAYS
COMBINED BETWEEN THE TWO TEAMS.
IT WAS A SPECIAL TEAMS
HERE'SER PLAY.
IT'S FREE. DEEP.
LEWISE.
LINDHOLM CAN'T SETTLE IT DOWN.
TONINATO TAKES CONTROL.
KEPT ONSIDE
PASS.
HE WILL BRING IT OUT.
LOOKING FOR ANDERSSON.
THAT'S STEERED IN.
OUT.
THAT DRAWS A WHISTLE JUST PAST
TOFFOLI.
PUCK PLAYED AROUND FOR LUCIC.
HE WILL BACKHAND LONG SHOT WELL
BACKLUND.
NEAL PIONK ONE OF THE BEST IN
THE LEAGUE AT WALKING THE THROUH
THE SECOND PERIOD.
MORRISSEY'S SHOT DEFLECTED IN
FRONTTECHNIKOV GETS THE PASS.
THAT WILL GO ALL THE WAY DOWN
FOR AN ICINGNGY.
>> Kelly: JETS HAVE HAD SOME
GOOD CHANCES THIS SECOND PERIOD.
>> Rick: THEY HAVE.
STANLEY ON T[ Horn ]
EIGHT GAMES IN A ROW WITH A GOAL
FOR ELIAS LINDHOLM.
OH, THAT MIGHT BE ONE OF THE
CLOSER ONES.
N THIS SITUATION.
E JUST  IT DOW.
NOW COLEMAN STEALS.
THREE FLAMES O
MOVE.
A GOOD PLAY BY DEMELO TO KNOESE
THE BOX.
>> Kelly: I WANT TO ECHO WHAT
RYAN A A BIT OF A
SWAT
HERE'S GAUDREAU.
GAUDREAU
BACKLUND.
ALSO ON THE REBOUND.
THE JETS HAVE THE PUCK.
THEY LOSE POSSESSION OF IT.
JOHNNY GOES TO OUTSIDE